Jeff ho was out with friends new Borough
Market on the night of the terrorist
attack he's only just come out of
hospital and is now telling his story I
got stabbed and firstly in the throat
they came here and then they tried to
stab me in the stomach and then to be
perfectly honest not certain how the one
here happened but that knife blade which
came at my votes severed the Adam's
apple and though everything is fine now
to be able to speak eat drink although I
can do it without putting pressure on
the bandage and holding in place it's a
lot easier to do so instead of going
home after the pub he decided to get
something to eat
it's a nearby restaurant and then the
attackers came they kicked in the door
and I knew instantly then because I saw
the suicide vet what looked like suicide
vests that I had to put myself in harm's
way and try and delay them because
otherwise they'll just go on a killing
spree when they came in they initially
started yelling get get on the floor
everyone get on the floor and lie down
on the floor and I knew that if anyone
did that they would just be dead
instantly the terrorists would just
start carving them up because you're
prone in that position you can't do
anything so all I tried to do was
actually put myself between them and my
friends and try and by the police time
because I knew they were in the area we
were effectively prepared to put your
life
yeah risk and I'd do it again in an
instant when they came at me they
attacked they got me in the throat I
tried to cap I think what happened was I
tried to actually parry the blades the
knife wounds on my hand suggested that I
tried to push them off that way and that
must I think that's what happened
because otherwise they would have got me
somewhere vital like one of the veins or
a minute the arteries and I would have
died instantly
what was it like to look at the me on
all I saw in their eyes was rage they
were so angry it was like no animals to
be perfectly honest and then when they
came at me was frenzied they were just
having everything they were just there
wasn't any calculation in it though just
really wanted you could tell they just
really wanted to hurt as many people as
possible and they didn't care about life
all I saw in them was rage any point did
you think that you might die it never
really crossed my mind until I actually
got to London Bridge itself that was
this one moment where I thought you know
what I just need to sit down for a bit
and close my eyes now that's why my
friend kept talking he said no don't
close your eyes keep talking keep
telling me what to do
just keep talking to me full stop just
say something I didn't really have time
to actually think about that at that
point I just wanted to close my eyes and
I suppose that was the moment when I
first thought you know what this is
really serious I know I'm not dead I
know I should if they were any better at
knife combat the terrorists would have
killed me out right there and then in
the restaurant but I've got a chance of
surviving this as long as they get me to
a hospital quickly I'm probably going to
make it I'll never forget seeing the
footage of myself walking over the
bridge bleeding out
I really wish my parents had never seen
anything right it seemed that no one
should have to see their kid do that
Jeff distracted the attackers long
enough for his friends to escape I don't
think of myself as a hero I just wanted
to do the right thing and help protect
my friends I think I did that and that's
what makes me happy
knowing that I gave my friends you know
the extra seconds maybe a minute or
whatever it was to get out of there